an nba owner admits he doesn't care
about the chinese uyghurs and he's not
the only member of the american elite
class who doesn't plus a new poll shows
republicans with a lead in voter
identification for the first time in a
very long time i'm bench bureau this is
the bench bureau show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressivevpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first did you know that you
don't just vote in november you vote
every single day i mean depending on who
you are spending your money with you
could be sending your money indirectly
to some of the people you really don't
want to be sending your money to so for
example if you're still a customer of
verizon or att or t-mobile you're
choosing to support the candidates that
they support which would mean like biden
pelosi schumer and company but here is a
solution pure talk see pure talk as i've
talked about uses the exact same tower
same 5g network as one of the big guys
but with the peace of mind that you are
supporting a veteran-run business a
business whose employees are right here
in the united states so yes this is a
monthly bill you can be proud to pay
plus you're going to be paying a lot
less on that bill than you would
normally with one of those big cell
phone coverage providers it'll be about
half of what your current cell phone
bill is because the average family saves
over 800 a year so do this today go to
puretalk.com find the plan that's right
for you find the phone that's right for
you or just bring your own then because
they love my listeners enter promo code
ben shapiro and you will save 50 off
your very first month of coverage that's
puretalk.com promo code ben shapiro go
check them out right now puretalk.com
promo code ben shapiro alrighty so
yesterday there is a billionaire nba
executive he is a part owner of the
of the warriors the golden state
warriors in california in san francisco
his name is chamath palihapatiya
okay so forgive me if i screwed up the
name and he was doing a podcast and i
have to say one of the most amazing
things about people who are
extraordinarily wealthy is that very
often they really think they know things
they do not know there's a famous line
from fiddler on the roof you know when
you're rich they think you really know
but but the truth is for some people
when they are very very very rich like
not just fu rich but f the whole world
rich
they start to think that they know all
the things they know everything about
politics they know everything about
world affairs they don't have to have
studied anything because after all the
proof is in the pudding and they are
worth a lot of money and they are not
even bound by the strictures of basic
morality and decency the reason that i
bring this up with regard to this
billionaire is because this billionaire
nba owner
who's the owner of one of the most
virtue signaling organizations in
america right the warriors whose coach
is steve kerr who is a very left-wing
guy he's virtue signaled on everything
from black lives matter to donald trump
the the team is a very left-leaning team
on everything from gay rights to
transgenderism
the entire social sort of
place of this team is to represent the
far left the owner of this team he came
out on a podcast and he said he does not
care about the chinese users he was
asked specifically about the nba's
relationship with china and he says it
just straight out now what's amazing
about this is that he has the gall to
say this openly on a podcast like this
isn't leaked audio it's not as though he
said this secretly on a phone call and
then it leaked into the public eye
he said this into a microphone on a
podcast he knew was being taped and he
apparently thought that this was a
perfectly moral thing to do and say
which is pretty incredible it really is
for for somebody who lives on the left
and i'm sure knows of the strictures of
cancellation
it's amazing that he felt comfortable
enough to say this directly into a
microphone but it does show what the
left actually believes about china and
its predations on the world stage so
here is what this billionaire nba
executive champion
had to say about the chinese
destruction of the uyghur community in
zhang
nobody cares about what's happening to
the weakers okay you you bring it up
because you really care and i think what
do you mean
the rest of us don't care i'm just
telling you a very hard you're saying
you eventually don't care i'm telling
you a very hard ugly truth okay of all
the things that i care about yes it is
below my line
okay of all the things that i care about
it is below my line
okay that's an amazing statement it's
below his line now what's amazing about
that too is that he then continued along
these lines what was above his line what
he said was above his line was climate
change so climate change was somehow
above his line but the the
imprisonment in concentration camps of a
million people by the chinese is below
his line
he said i care about yeah i care about
the fact that our economy could turn on
a time if china invades taiwan i care
about that i care about climate change
you know i care about a bunch i care
about america's crippling and decrepit
healthcare infrastructure but if you're
asking me do i care about a segment of a
class of people in another country not
until we can take care of ourselves will
i prioritize them over us and i think a
lot of people believe that and i'm sorry
if that's a hard truth to hear but every
time i say i care about the uyghurs i'm
really just lying if i don't really care
and so i'd rather not lie to you and
tell you the truth it's not a priority
for me
he said until america actually cleans up
our own house the idea that we step
outside of our borders with you know a
sort of morally virtue signaling about
somebody else's human rights track
record is deplorable it's deplorable
this is by the way how the left things
the left in the united states believes
that the united states is the root of
all evil and so we must spend all of our
time naval gazing about the evils of the
united states while simultaneously
allowing him to do business in china
which is really what this is about see
when when folks on the left talk about
climate change very often they don't
really mean they care very much about
climate change they're happy to take
their private shots they're more than
happy to consume extraordinary amounts
of carbon and create massive carbon
emissions climate change is just an
excuse to show that you care about
things that you don't actually care
about it's an excuse to say you're a
good person it is the ultimate virtue
signal it's like save the whales in the
1970s like the way that you demonstrated
to the world that you cared about things
even if you were enjoying your
highfalutin lifestyle was to say that
you wanted to save the whales then it
became safe to bat right for a little
while it was safe to bat camera traction
was a pretty good cause
i mean listen i like whales too but
let's be real about this the vast
majority of people who are slapping a
save the whale's bumper sticker on the
back of their car or then consuming
inordinate amounts of plastic and then
dumping them into the ocean so this this
silly thing that you see people like
chumath palapatiya saying i don't care
about a million uyghurs in slavery in
china what i do care about is climate
change you have bullcrap i don't think
you care about climate change either i
don't think you care about any of these
things i think what you care about is
virtue signaling to your own left base
while being able to do business with the
people who make you richer which is what
this is really about
the reason that he is saying he doesn't
care about this is so that he can defend
china and so that he can rip on the
united states if your moral compass is
so skewed you spend all day long talking
about the evils of the country that has
made you rich and famous
and allowed you ownership of a major
sports franchise while simultaneously
poo pooing the human rights violations
of the chinese communist party some of
the worst human rights violations in
human history
this chinese communist party is
responsible for the 40 million people in
the great leap forward responsible for
the
for the yearly forced abortion of
hundreds of thousands millions of
children over the course of decades
responsible now for the subjection of
the entire population of hong kong to
sheer tyranny the imprisonment of a
million uyghurs and threats to taiwan
right that doesn't bother you at all but
climate change is your pr i don't
believe you
i don't belie i don't think you're being
perfectly honest i think if you were
perfectly honest what you say is you
don't care about the weakers and you
also don't claire about care about
climate change and you also you also
don't care about the social justice
warrior nonsense what you actually care
about is getting very wealthy and
demonstrating to your friends at the
cocktail parties that you're really
really
well-versed and in in these in the
demands of woke culture
and like he continued along these lines
again he says quote look at the number
of black and brown men that are
incarcerated for absolutely ridiculous
crimes i don't know if you saw this past
week there's a person released from jail
because he couldn't even be protected in
jail because in some of these cells they
run these fight clubs inside of rikers
that are basically tacitly tacitly
endorsed by the corrections officers
that didn't do that don't do anything
so if you want to talk about the human
rights of people i think we have a
responsibility to take care of our own
backyard first first and then we can go
and basically morally tell other people
how they should be running their own
countries uh no i'm pretty sure that we
don't actually have to fix the problems
at rikers island to point out that
killing that taking a million people of
a different religion and shoving them
into a concentration camp and forcing
them to live in slavery
and forcibly sterilizing their women i
i'm pretty sure that no matter what
happens at rikers we can say that's bad
see the thing is that this is something
that the
folks on the radical left they love to
do they love to claim that you're a
hypocrite if you say that we should look
at human rights in china
but you haven't taken care of all your
own problems at home first
now what they are really doing is saying
you shouldn't have any standards at all
on the global stage
because no matter what the antecedent is
the consequence in the sentence is going
to be so we shouldn't pay attention to
the uyghurs and the reason for that is
because he's making a lot of money off
the chinese
it comes down to money
i mean this is a cynical take but it's
real for the nba for the lebron james's
and for the chamath palais patias it
comes down to the cold hard cash
and shemoth continued along these lines
he said because it wasn't just enough to
say listen china's got its problems
we've got our problems we should solve
our problems first he then continued by
actively downplaying the dictatorship of
xi jinping in china
i'm not even sure that that it china is
a dictatorship the way that you want to
call it that
again i think there's a country that's
in the name look you have to understand
jason there are a set of checks and
balances here on china that you know at
the end of the day
i don't think that i have the moral
absolutism to judge china and i would
say that when nato is silent the united
nations is silent all of western europe
is silent and america is effectively
silent that this issue may be
small data points being extrapolated in
a way to create a narrative that maybe
not be true
did xi jinping write this guy like in a
lab this is unbelievable stuff by the
way the reason the united nations is
silent is because china is on the
security council they can veto anything
it's like saying you know the u.n is
really silent about russian predations
in crimea yeah because russia can veto
anything on the security council
you want to know why the eu is silent on
china because the eu will do whatever it
can in order to keep china in its corner
the same way this guy will
the the dirty little secret about the
opening of china is that china used
capitalism to worm its way into power in
a wide variety of countries by making
its market dependent on the rest of the
world cow towing to it and the rest of
the world went well okay well i guess we
can't care anymore about them doing evil
things as long as we can sell cheap
product in china and manufacture cheap
products in china
it really is an incredible thing
right the the response
from from
chamath is is pretty insane
it really is
you know the the the
belief system that america is so evil
that we have nothing to say about
chinese predations
i i would i wouldn't believe it if he
said it
and i really don't believe when he's
making money off of china so the
warriors then put out a statement about
chamath palapatiya's statement quote as
a limited investor who has no day-to-day
operating functions with the warriors mr
palapatiya does not speak on behalf of
our franchise and his views certainly
don't reflect those of our organization
okay i noticed a few words that you
didn't mention in that statement golden
state warriors you didn't use the word
china and you didn't use the word uighur
i noticed that by the way he then put
out a statement trying to walk this back
and his statement trying to walk this
back is egregiously vague quote in
re-listening to this week's podcast i
recognize that i come across as lacking
empathy i acknowledge that entirely as a
refugee my family fled a country with
its own set of human rights issues so
this is something that is very much a
part of my lived experience to be clear
my belief is that human rights matter
whether in china the united states or
elsewhere full stop
well
no that's not your belief now i think
you're lying
i also noticed that you didn't mention
the chinese uyghurs anywhere in that
statement
and the problem here is not a lack of
empathy the problem here is that
you just
value your cash more than you value
actual values and this is true for so
many of these it's amazing how many
virtue signaling companies in the united
states
all these companies that are using
virtue signaling to market because let's
be let's be frank about this during the
black lives matter protest of 2020 when
the corporate world dumped 23
billion with ab dollars into various
causes promoted by black lives matter
that was a payoff it was a pure
corporate payoff it was an attempt to
get all of the woksters to leave them
alone it was an attempt not only that to
capitalize on the wokesters it was an
attempt to say to the black community of
the united states which the media
assured us was 100 behind defund the
police which of course is not true
it was corporations attempting to appeal
to a particular demographic by throwing
money at the problem and pretending that
they as a corporate culture had moved
into woke territory so leave us alone
and allow us to make our money and not
only that why don't you spend money with
us because if you spend money with us
then you're backing the cause
when it comes to china however the
problem is they're making more money off
of china than they are losing money from
people in the united states who refuse
to do business with them this is a very
simple business calculation for all
these businesses including the nba
including chamath palehipatia
the calculation is this if they rip
china china cuts off the market
if they don't rip china china leaves the
market open and the number of people in
the united states are upset enough to
turn off an nba game is enos canter
right the the those are the that is the
total number of people in the united
states who care enough and this is why
he's going to get away with this he'll
say it and it won't be a problem lebron
james hell said it and no one cared
because either they're right and no one
cares about the uyghurs or as it turns
out most people just want to watch
basketball and they can get away with
nearly anything but that should
demonstrate full scale how cynical they
are when it comes to their other causes
too
it's not that they care about black
lives matter and they don't care about
the weaker they don't care about any of
these things they don't care about any
of these things they are pure
money-making machines
so the question becomes if you're on the
right or if you're just an american who
doesn't like chinese predations the
question becomes
why are you falling for it
right either you push back or these
folks are going to
do whatever is most
on their bottom line whatever makes
their bottom line the strongest is what
they're going to do which means virtue
signaling to the woke because the woke
are willing to number one
leave the profit margins of the nba
alone so long as the nba
does its performative ritual malice
struggle sessions on race
so they can they can make money there
and they can make money in china as long
as they don't piss off the chinese so if
you actually want the nba to change its
behavior
then you're going to have to push on the
other side you're going to say to the
nba no
no we are not going to patronize your
games no we are not going to spend money
on the warriors no we are not going to
buy your gear
you have to become as militant
on the on the pro-america side as so
many on the left are on the anti-america
side
because right now
you have a complete imbalance of power
when it comes to the right and the left
when it comes to corporate america in
this country the left can manipulate
corporate america by trying to exert
pressure
both market pressure and regulatory
pressure and the right sits there
they're like well we'll buy whatever
product is necessary this is why i've
said there must be some sort of mutually
assured destruction that is brought to
bear on these massive companies now
mutually assured destruction must say
either you guys stay completely
apolitical and you stay out of politics
entirely or you're gonna get clocked
because if you move to the left you'll
get clocked by the right and if you move
to the right you'll get clocked by the
left
and then there'll be a neutrality that
is put in place and so that has to
happen from a popular level in the
united states but there's something else
that has to happen here and that is that
the west has to start seeing china as
the threat that it is because it's not
just that china is a military threat
it's not just that china has a huge
military arsenal and they're pointing it
at places like taiwan and they're
attempting to choke off the south china
sea and they're attempting to affect
shipping straits and they are
threatening australia right that's not
just the problem with china the problem
with china is that they are militarizing
our own institutions against us
because china has realized the game
they've been able to weaponize the power
of capitalism in order to pervert all
the businesses that want to do business
in china
we'll get to more of that in just one
second first
let us talk about a simple fact okay you
are on your bed eight hours a night if
you're doing it right and that means
that you need a great pair of sheets so
the other night i was talking to my
parents and my parents they were saying
you know we just got a pair of bowl and
brand sheets and i had never slept on a
pair of golden brand sheets before and
now i can't sleep on any other sheets
this is what my mom said to me she said
for years i had been sleeping on sheets
that were not bowling branch and then i
got bowling branch and let me just say
they are unbelievable well i knew that
already i told her this years ago
because my wife and i sleep on bowling
brand sheets and we have been doing so
four years these are the best sheets on
the market you should go ahead and get
them
the fact they're not
cheap garbage like you'd buy at the
local
bed and bath store
that is because these are really really
good okay they are worth the money the
signature hem sheets from bowling branch
are the bestseller for a reason buttery
soft lightweight organic cotton and a
classic sateen weave for sheets that get
softer over time they're not too hot
they're not too cool they're the perfect
year-round sheets for most sleepers bull
and branch signature sheets come in
seven beautiful colors in all sizes from
twin all the way on up to california
king they are made to a higher standard
100 organic cotton ethical production
thoughtful attention to every detail
there's also nothing worse than fitted
sheets that don't fit you put them on
the mattress and then halfway through
the night your face is directly on the
mattress because you've rolled around it
sort of popped off the mattress not so
with bull and branch get the best sheets
you've ever felt at bull and branch dot
com get 15 off your first set of sheets
when you use promo code shapiro at
checkout that's bull and branch b-o-l-l
and branch dot com promo code shapiro go
check them out right now so again it's
not just the nba
okay it is also apple
so there's an article
from a website called the
information.com
and this this website discusses what
exactly
the the apple corporation has done in
order to please
the the
insane
dictat of the chinese
and here's what they say
they say if you've used an iphone 13 and
apple watch or airpods chances are
you've touched the handiwork of lux
share which assembles them over the past
decade it became the biggest chinese
manufacturer of consumer electronics
luxury got to this vaulted position
because of apple and this of course is
true okay apple made lux share a massive
massive thing
lux share apparently has the potential
to unseat foxconn as apple's top
supplier the chinese company already
exceeds foxconn's main publicity listed
unit in terms of market capitalization
though foxconn generated roughly 105
billion dollars from apple in 2020 more
than 10 times lux shares hull but in
terms of valuation luxure has also
eclipsed major apple contractors such as
quantum computer pegatron and wistron
all of which are headquartered in taiwan
foxconn has become increasingly
concerned about luxury's meteoric rise
including its significantly higher net
profit margin going so far as to form a
task force to study the company reuters
previously reported
according to this website the
information
in shifting more business to chinese
companies
apple head tim cook
the architect of apple supply chain in
china is fulfilling his pledge to
beijing to expand its domestic tech
industry which will help the country
reduce its reliance on companies based
outside the mainland including taiwan a
country china considers a renegade
region a year after tim cook signed the
economic agreement with china luxury
became the first chinese company to
secure a final assembly contract for a
major lap major apple product the air
pods ending the dominance of taiwanese
firms
apple's moves might win over more
chinese consumers which at times have
shunned apple in favor of local brands
like huawei based on nationalism apple
generates nearly 20 of all global
revenue from china
that's the reason why tim cook pledged
275 billion dollars in investment to the
chinese government
a turning point for luxury according to
the information came in 2017.
when apple helped the company
manufacture airpods apple originally
relied on a single source taiwan based
inventec to produce the iconic earbuds
which were in short supply in their
first year of release apple embedded its
engineers at luxury to teach the company
how to assemble the devices over the
course of the year according to formal
app of former apple employees the
airpods were luxur's first major
assembly contract for apple catapulting
the company into the upper echelons of
apple suppliers that handle pack and
ship finished goods so you want to know
why it is that there hasn't been a
full-scale hardcore investigation of the
chinese creation of the wuhan virus in
the lab you want to know why there has
not been a full investigation into that
why china has been able to stonewall
that because everyone is dependent on
china they've created manufacturing
chains they have they have provided a
billion a two billion person market in
china to all these major corporations
all these major corporations don't want
to be cut off at the knees
china is gaining power over rare earth
minerals that are necessary for the
creation of the microchips that go in
everything from your cars to your
computers
china has become a centralized economic
powerhouse in terms of what it is
capable of leveraging on the world stage
so it is not that china is inordinately
economic power economically powerful as
we'll get to in just a moment actually
china is is sort of a hollow
it's sort of a hollow bear
okay but the fact of the matter is that
china can still leverage whatever power
it has on the global stage in order to
get everybody to do its bidding
this is happening in hollywood as well
so it's not just apple apple cowtows to
china because apple is creating more and
more of its products it provides 20 of
apple's entire market
apple is undercutting its competition by
doing production in china so you think
that tim cook is going to speak out
against chinese predations same thing in
the nba the nba is making billions of
dollars in china and they see china as
their future as their future market so
they're not going to alienate the
chinese this is why you have lebron
james and chamath palipatia defending
chinese predations against uighur
muslims because they're making too much
money over there they're manufacturing
half their goods over there right that
nba jersey you're wearing was probably
made in china
and the nba isn't willing to undercut
its own profit margins in order to make
a statement about the chinese treatment
of muslims in one region of china
no way
it's also affecting our culture right
our cultural creators are in hock to
china we'll get to that in just one
moment first if you run an e-commerce
business you know that the most
agonizing parts are things like
responding to where's my package emails
or processing returns dealing with
expensive shipping charges stamps.com
takes the pain out of shipping by giving
you access to deeply discounted shipping
options and integrating with the most
popular online shopping platforms to
make labeling a breeze set yourself up
to focus on the good stuff this year by
saving time and money on shipping with
stamps.com here at dailywire we've been
using stamps.com since 2017 we do not
waste our time you're gonna save tons of
money when you shift over to stamps.com
you get up to 40 off usps rates and up
to 76 off ups it integrates with the
most popular online marketplaces and
shopping carts including amazon etsy
shopify and ebay stamps.com
automatically connects to your online
stores and brings in the shipping info
for all your orders you can simply print
that shipping label from any standard
printer you stick it to the package and
then you schedule a pickup or drop them
off no traffic no lines and with their
tracking tools and automated delivery
notification emails you can avoid those
dreaded where's the package and what's
my return status messages start saving
time and money on shipping today with
stamps.com no risk with my promo code
shapiro you get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital shipping scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the home page type in
shapiro that is stamps.com promo code
shapiro stamps.com easy e-commerce
shipping for less alrighty so it is not
just the nba
our sports product it is not just apple
our technology products it's also of
course hollywood so hollywood has been
attempting to make nice with the chinese
market for a very long time because the
chinese movie market is enormous
and china has been really flexing its
muscles on this thing the hollywood
reporter has an entire piece from late
december titled this year hollywood's
china relationship finally unraveled
it doesn't matter how accommodating the
industry may be the next phase of xi
jinping's era may be defined by less
space for western content
and here is what the hollywood reporter
says
in 2014 when warner brothers drafted
lebron james to star in its space jam
sequel the film was tailored to appeal
above all else to the mighty chinese
market after all james is a huge
commodity in the basketball obsessed
country where his signature nike
sneakers are made along the way the
future hall of famer avoided poking the
china bear even if it meant drawing
outrage when he criticized houston
rocket's gm daryl mori in 2019 for
tweeting his support for hong kong
protesters calling him misinformed a
notable move given james vocal stance on
police brutality issues and former
president trump's so-called muslim
travel ban at the time videos of police
crackdowns on hong kong's pro-democracy
movement were circulating wildly while
it was well reported that more than a
million uyghur muslims were being held
in internment camps despite attempts to
make it past china's censors space jam a
new legacy never received a release in
china this summer and scored just 162.8
million dollars worldwide a so-so figure
even given the coronavirus pandemic that
is a nice way of putting it space jam a
new legacy was a bomb still space gem
was not alone china disney received the
same cold shoulder when it came to its
marvel tentpoles shangshi and the legend
of the ten rings and the eternals films
that were built around chinese talent in
order to make a giant showing in the
market but to no avail neither film was
given a release in the country that
continues to take heat for reported
human rights abuses hollywood's silence
on those abuses has become deafening as
other industries and entities have begun
to confront china
in fact 2021 might mark the year that
finally cooled the hollywood china
romance warner media studios and
networks group chair and ceo ann sarnoff
told thr i think we're still feeling our
way through that new paradigm obviously
there's been a lot of geopolitical meta
issues happening with changes of our
government trying to figure out what the
new relationship's going to be with the
biden administration china is clearly
building its own local theatrical
business the numbers are very large and
we would like to believe we're going to
be a big part of their future but we're
honestly taking it one movie at a time
i'm not making any grand predictions
because i don't know but it's something
we're very very aware of and front
burner because when you do your
ultimates and your green lights china
was a big chunk of it
the theatrical film market is still
limited and there are a bunch of movies
that have sat on the shelf because of
perceived political slights or for no
perceptible reason at all these include
black widow venom let there be carnage
and now potentially spider-man no way
home and at the same time says the
hollywood reporter hollywood has lost
any semblance of a moral high ground it
has been lost on few that the industry
remained mum when global superstar fan
bingbing went missing in 2018
including her agency caa by contrast the
women's tennis association this month
pulled all of its tournaments in china
following a similar disappearance of
tennis star pengui
as hollywood's risk reward calculus for
china starts to get muddier and muddier
there's a move for an entity whether
it's a celebrity athlete or company to
do what muhammad ali did which is to
take a direct hit short term on revenue
but long term create a brand that's
bigger than what they're originally
known for said blockers producer chris
fenton whose 2020 book feeding the
dragon inside the trillion dollar
dilemma facing hollywood the nba and
american business explored the china
minefield
so boston celtics center enos cancer
freedom who is really doing heroic
things on this he has seized on this
blasted lebron james for looking the
other way of course
meanwhile the planned u.s diplomatic
boycott of the beijing winter olympics
will only escalate china's growing
enmity toward united states culture and
corporations are just going to keep
surrendering on this
and here's the thing china has to use
its leverage so just as the soviet union
was a second-rate power masquerading as
a first-rate power china is a
second-rate power masquerading as a
first-rate power they are not an
economic powerhouse china
is an extraordinarily large population
they've opened up their market to the
extent that they have been
able to
take
hundreds of millions of their own
citizens out of abject poverty but the
simple fact of the matter is that china
is not a widely prosperous country
china's gdp per capita is still about 10
and that is their gdp per capita the
united states gdp per capita
is currently 63 500
so our gdp per capita is about six times
that of china right canada is four times
that of china the uk's is four times
that of china so when you're talking
about economic power houses if you're
gonna rank
if you're gonna rank countries by gdp
per capita
the simple fact of the matter is that
china is ranked on a global level in
terms of gdp per capita according to
world odometers below libya montenegro
mexico thailand azerbaijan and iraq okay
so china is not a global economic
powerhouse except that they have tons
and tons and tons of people and they can
use that leverage in order to force
people to do what they want they can
use the pressure points that are
inherent in capitalism to get particular
corporations to bend to their will and
this is what they have to do in the same
way that russia has to invade
surrounding countries in order to
demonstrate to their population that the
country has a future and they're a
muscular player on the world stage even
though the fact is that russia is indeed
a second rate power with a second-rate
economy and a decrepit military
structure russia's gdp per capita is is
also quite terrible russia's gdp per
capita right now is on par with china's
about 10 000 bucks per person
right those are bad numbers okay but
all these countries have to demonstrate
their muscular on the world stage what
china has figured out is that using its
market it can actually create the
perception of widespread power and using
its massive military can threaten
surrounding countries
which would mean that the best way for
the united states to fight china would
be on the economic stage in the same way
that we fought the soviet union okay we
did not foster vast economic connections
between ourselves and the soviet union
the middle of the cold war that would
have been incredibly stupid it would
have made american companies dependent
on the soviet union and yet the entire
west
fell prey to the belief that if we
started to plant mcdonald's in china
somehow this would overthrow the chinese
communist party
that of course is untrue it turns out
that dictators can take advantage of
slightly open markets to enrich
themselves and create a cadre of
overlords who are able to suppress the
rest of the population
and this is exactly what china has to do
because china has serious problems
china is only a threat to the west in so
far as the west allows china to be a
threat to the west
that's the reality of the situation
because china internally is
extraordinarily weak according to the
new york times china announced on monday
that its birth rate plummeted for the
fifth straight year in 2021 moving the
world's most populous country closer to
the potentially seismic moment when its
population will begin to shrink
hastening and demographic crisis that
could undermine its economy and even its
political stability
the following birth rate coupled with an
increasing life expectancy that has
accompanied china's economic
transformation over the last four
decades means the number of people of
working age relative to the growing
number of people too old to work
has continued to decline in other words
they have a social welfare structure
that is completely upside down it is no
longer a pyramid it is now a top-heavy
pyramid
and there are not enough people at the
bottom of the pyramid to support all the
people at the top of the pyramid
this could result in labor shortages
which could hamper economic growth
reduce tax revenue needed to support an
aging society the situation is creating
a huge political problem for beijing
which is already facing economic
headwinds along with the demographic
data the country reported on monday that
growth in the last quarter of the year
slowed to four percent
china's ruling communist party has been
attempting to push people to have three
kids after spending years forcibly
murdering children okay this is a thing
that the chinese government
did do you want to watch a great
documentary on this a really disturbing
documentary there's a great documentary
called one child nation available on
amazon by a producer who actually is
from china the director who's from china
all about how china essentially led to
widespread infanticide through its one
child policy but none of this has been
able to reverse the stark fact an
increasing number of chinese women don't
want children
if john a professor at the university of
wisconsin madison
says china is facing a demographic
crisis that is beyond the imagination of
the chinese authorities and the
international community the number of
births in china fell to 10.6 million in
2021 compared with 12 million the year
before that was fewer even the number in
1961 when the great leap forward
resulted in widespread famine and death
for the first time since the great leap
forward china's population could soon
begin to contract the number of people
who died in 2021 10.1 million approached
the number of those who were born
some democrats say the peak may have
already occurred
wang fang professor of sociology at
university of california irvine says the
year 2021 will go down in chinese
history as the year china last saw
population growth in its long history
okay this is a disaster area for the
chinese economy
and in fact china's economy is slowing
again
i mean china is a debt-based economy
china has massive debt problems
china has been taking out money to pay
for basically building empty cities
over the course of the last
several decades at this point
i mean china has a massive public debt
according to war on the rocks dot com
china's riddled with debts china's one
of the most indebted large economies in
the world its state-owned banks are
sitting on mountains of bad debts and
non-performing loans particularly in the
real estate sector and that's just on
the surface underneath lies a staggering
quantity of murky debt off-balance sheet
lending wealth management products local
government funding vehicles all told
china's debt is considerably larger than
it appears at first glance and so high
that some analysts feel is it it is at
dangerous levels and could spill over
doing severe damage to the world economy
that is not a huge shock i mean china
has been basically staving off the
complete collapse of its second largest
real estate developer ever grand they
failed to pay a short-term debt in june
of 2021 and the chinese government had
to freeze the company's bank accounts
there were concerns the company might
default on its 305 billion dollars in
liabilities
and of course in october there's another
chinese developer fantasia holdings
group that missed its repayment of 206
million dollars in five year dollar
bonds later that same month china's
property group subsidiary cheer gain
group defaulted on 226 million dollars
worth of debt payments
another developer modern land china
missed its payment of principle or
interest on a 250 million dollar bond it
turns out that centralized economics is
garbage it is really really bad and when
you decide that you're going to prop up
your failing economic system by just
borrowing money
despite the fact that china was now
reported as the world's largest
recipient of foreign direct investment
well this means that you are
you are in real trouble
all this is being reported by antonio
graceffo a phd china mba who spent seven
years in china and is the author of the
books beyond the belt and road and a
short course on the chinese economy
so china has real economic problems that
means that their solutions their
economic problems is aggressiveness when
you have a failing country you get
aggressive and china's getting
aggressive on the world stage and
they're particularly turning toward
capitalism as a weak point for the west
because you can manipulate all these
sucker capitalists into doing business
with you and ignoring all of your
predations on the world stage by
offering them a little bit of cold hard
cash you can essentially bribe them into
ignoring what you're doing in the world
which is why you actually do need
government to stand up here
the american government should be
working with the europeans in order to
cut off china's economy at the knees
see china for what it is an aggressive
world power this is not a partnership
they're an enemy if the chinese
government has openly declared itself so
if you if you read any of the minutes
from their annual meetings their annual
meetings are all about how they are
going to take on and defeat the west
and yet we are allowing our own
corporations to be hijacked by the
chinese government propaganda outfit
it's insane
so in other words don't believe any of
these corporate heads when they pretend
that they are woke beyond woke they're
not woke beyond woke they're just
seeking money this holds true in terms
of foreign policy and it holds true
domestically as well
we got to push back on this because
capitalism can be used by militant
leftists in order to essentially turn
all of these corporations into their own
meat puppets and that's precisely what
they've been doing already in just one
second we'll get some good news on the
polling front first let's talk about
your sleep quality so we've talked about
the sheets that you put on your bed but
what kind of mattress are you using you
need a mattress made just for you this
is why you need helix sleep everybody's
unique helix knows that this is why they
created a sleep quiz for you and then
they create a mattress based on that
two-minute sleep quiz they've got
several different mattress models to
choose from they've got soft medium and
firm mattresses mattresses great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
mattresses great for spinal alignment to
prevent morning aches and pains even a
helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers helix even has mattresses with
special cooling technology if you and
your family can never agree on the
temperature of the thermostat so if
you're looking for a mattress you take
the quiz you order the mattress you
match to the mattress comes right to
your doorship for free you don't ever
need to go to a mattress store again
helix is awesome you don't need to take
my word for it helix is awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by both gq and wired magazine helix
has been recommended by multiple leading
chiropractors and doctors of sleep
medicine as a go-to solution for
improving sleep they have a 10-year
warranty you get to try it out for 100
nights risk-free they'll even pick it up
for you if you don't love it but you
will helix even has financing options
flexible payment plans so a great
night's sleep is never far away just go
to helixleep.com
take their two minutes sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
go check them out right now alrighty in
just one second we'll get to some
amazing amazing polling data
first if you haven't yet picked up your
copy of 1984 from my monthly book club
do it right now because in just a few
days here a couple of days we're going
to launch the third thursday book club
i'm super pumped about it we're going to
go through a massive classic in western
literature once a month for obvious
reasons orwell's
infamous 1984 seems like the perfect
place to start not only will the book
club hold you accountable for your
reading because you get through the
entire year you're going to read 12
fantastic books you're going to be so
much more well read some of these books
are really tough some of these books are
are classics some of these books are
things that maybe you read before but
you don't remember them because they
were back in high school we're going to
go through all of them with you then on
the third thursday of each month i will
join dailywire all access members online
for an in-depth lecture and discussion
of each book you can ask me questions
directly right now get 25 off an all
access membership with code 1984 over at
dailywear.com
subscribe by the way this makes a
fantastic gift for a college student a
high school student i get this question
all the time how do i teach my kids to
read how do i teach my kids how to
engage with classic material this is a
great way to get started if you haven't
already joined it's not too late to sign
up just head on over to third
thursdaybookclub.com receive the
materials you will need to participate
in my first members only all access
discussion and don't forget head on over
to dailywire.com subscribe join as an
all access member with 25 off using code
1984. i cannot wait to hang out with you
and discuss orwell this thursday january
20th 8 p.m eastern 7 00 pm central also
i am pumped to announce the release of
the final trailer for our first original
movie here at daily wire shut in it's a
seat gripping thriller that will be
available to stream right here at daily
wire in early february it really is
fantastic fantastic stuff here is some
of the trailer
now
you
must pay
your daughter
she's very pretty
i'm scared
okay it is uh it is definitely not for
the kitties it is it is a great
creepy thriller it's got some messages
that are pretty fantastic as well go to
shutinfilm.com to watch the full trailer
get ready for the film's release
february 10th the film is indeed
exclusive to daily wire if you're
planning on adding this terrifying
thriller to your queue and you want us
to keep making content to combat the
insane leftism of the major platforms
head on over to dailywire.com subscribe
become a member today also tonight the
daily wire was one of the first in the
nation to file suit against the biden
administration's tyrannical vax mandate
and we won because that's what we do
here winning all the time tune in
tonight catch an all-new episode of
backstage we're going to discuss the
outcome of the supreme court ruling and
so much more join me jeremy boring
michael mills matt walsh and andrew
clavin tonight 7 p.m eastern 6 p.m
central on dailywire.com and on our
youtube channel daily wire you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty meanwhile there's some
astonishing news from the polling front
okay on the polling front democrats are
in such unbelievable trouble according
to gallup on average america's political
preferences in 2021 looked similar to
prior years with slightly more u.s
adults identifying as democrats or
leaning democratic than identified as
republicans or leaning republican about
46 democratic and 43 republican however
the general stability for the full-year
average obscures a dramatic shift over
the course of 2021 from a nine
percentage point democratic advantage in
the first quarter of 2021 to a
five-point republican edge in the fourth
quarter 47 percent identified as
republican or lean republican compared
to 42 percent who identified as lean
democrat and that is extraordinarily
rare
the nine-point democratic advantage in
the first quarter and the five-point
republican edge in the fourth quarter
are among the largest gallup has
measured for either party in any quarter
since it began regularly measuring party
id and leaning in 1991.
the gop has held as much as a five-point
advantage in a total of only four
quarters since 1991.
the republicans last held a five-point
advantage in party identification and
leaning in early 1995 after winning
control of the house of representatives
for the first time since the 50s so
basically the last time there was a
giant enormous unprecedented republican
wave
that was 1994
and that is when republican numbers
looked like this one
the only other time the republicans had
a larger advantage is when george w bush
was at like 90 in the approval ratings
at the beginning of the gulf war
okay for democrats their lead in the
first quarter was the largest for the
party since the first fourth quarter of
2012 which is of course when barack
obama won re-election
shifting party preferences in 2021
according to gallup are likely tied to
changes in popularity of the two men who
served as president during the year
donald trump finished out his single
term in january after being defeated in
2020 with a 34 job approval rating
that's the lowest of his term his
popularity fell more than 10 points from
election day 2020 as the country's
coveted 19 infections and deaths reached
record highs as well as the january 6th
events
meanwhile joe biden had relatively high
ratings and then those absolutely
collapsed
and so what we saw in the fourth quarter
is this massive shift toward the
republicans
according to gallup the shifts in party
affiliation in each quarter of 2021 were
apparent in both the percentage
identifying with each party and the
percentage of independence leaning to
each party but with more changes among
leaners than identifiers
between the first and fourth quarters
the percentage of democratic identifiers
decreased by two points the percentage
of democratic leaning independence
dropped by five points
republican identification increased by
three points republican leaners
increased by four points
okay so that is a that is a massive
shift in favor of the republicans it is
extremely rare
and uh and democrats are in real and
serious trouble
not just that according to gallup
you can see what has happened within the
parties and this is the reason why
there's been a shift against the
democrats so if you look at americans
political ideology by year
across the country
about 36 percent of americans identify
as conservative another 37 percent of
americans identify as moderate that
means that 73 of americans are either
conservative or moderate
how many identify as liberal
so that is a a
not great number for the folks on the
left particularly because all of those
liberals identify only with the
democratic party
the democratic party used to be a lot
more politically diverse
but the simple fact of the matter is
that right now the democratic party has
moved in a wildly left direction if you
look at the democrats political ideology
according to gallup what it shows is
that in 1994 only 25 percent of
democrats identified as liberal right
about 20 same number identified as
conservative so it was about 25
conservative 25 liberal and about 50
moderate
today
only 12 percent of democrats identify as
conservative 37
identify as moderate 50 identify as
liberal so liberals remember only
constitute about 25 of the entire
american population but they are 50 of
the democratic party
moderates constitute only about 37
percent of the democratic party down
from 48 in 1994
and there are no conservatives left in
the democratic party 12 percent of
democrats identify as conservatives
meanwhile the numbers for independence
have remained essentially the same
in 1994 46 identified as moderate today
that's 48
31 identified as conservative today
that's 30
18 identified as liberal today that's 20
so in other words the democratic party
moved to the left and now everybody else
has moved to the right
that's the story of american politics
the republican party identifies more
openly as conservative but the moderates
have been left behind by the democratic
party
which is a disaster for the democratic
and you can see that these demographics
are really bad for the democratic party
if you look at americans political
ideology by subgroup in 2021
what you see
is that only people 18 to 29
predominantly identify as liberal
and the the vast majority of people
in the united states first of all the
vast majority of people or plurality of
people 18 to 29 identify as moderate but
among people who identify as liberal the
plurality are young 18 to 29.
among people who identify as
conservative
the plurality are older
and moderates are sort of evenly spread
across the board well here's the problem
this is an older country gang
so the demographics actually do not run
in favor of the democratic party at this
point
and here is what's particularly
hilarious okay here is how racial groups
identify you ready so this is totally
contrary to what the left would like you
to believe here's how racial groups
identify politically
non-hispanic white adults
42 identify
as conservative 34 identify as moderate
23 identify as liberal
among non-hispanic black adults 20
identify as conservative
26 identify as liberal
51 identify as moderate among blacks
among black americans
okay so in other words there are more
liberals than conservatives among blacks
about six percent
but virtually all black people like 51
of them identify as moderate hispanics
it's way worse for the democratic party
here among hispanics 31 of hispanics
identify as conservative 28 identify as
liberal more hispanics now identify as
conservative than liberal and 38
identify as moderates
so as the democratic party it's more and
more liberal
they are leaving behind the entire
american population
and yet joe biden
is held hostage by his own base because
50 of his party is progressive
and most of his activist base
so what the hell is he going to do
right he's left the entire center of
american politics wide open this is
what's so astonishing about joe biden's
presidency all he had to do was have a
little bit of guts nate silver the poll
analyst
he made a really good point but people
tend to think of joe biden as moderate
joe biden is joe biden is not a moderate
says nate silver joe biden is a person
who is wherever the center of the
democratic party is so if the center of
the democratic party moves to the left
so does joe biden so joe biden's a
bellwether he's not a leader he's a
bellwether so if joe biden moved into
bernie sanders territory it's because
his base is in bernie sanders territory
the problem is the country ain't in
bernie sanders territory so the more
democrats reflect this the more
democrats move to the left and by the
way
studies demonstrate the republican their
republican platform has basically been
stagnant since 2010
democratic platform has moved wildly to
the left
as they've done this joe biden has moved
along with them
so it's not that joe biden is just a
fool who moved to the left
although i think he is a fool for not
standing up it's that this is who joe
biden always was he was the cork bobbing
on the eddies of democratic party
politics and wherever the democratic
party was that is where he was well
democratic party politics is now
completely disconnected from the
american population the only reason joe
biden was elected is because he was not
donald trump that was not a green light
to all of the idiotic democratic
strategies it was not a green light to
all of their garbage policies
and it is hilarious that the democrats
keep trying to ram down policies the
american people hate and then they look
around think
why why doesn't anybody follow us the
answer is because your party is not
reflective of the american population
by the way roy tashera right remember
he's the guy who suggested a new
emerging democratic majority he said
that as more minorities
were were present in the demographics of
american life there would be a radical
shift over to the left in american
politics
he came out with an article just a few
weeks ago saying that the hispanic vote
was moving conservative and this broke
his model he came out yesterday he said
uh guys the asian vote is moving
conservative it's breaking my model
because it's not that they're moving
conservative it's that everyone is now
ronald reagan circa 1964.
everybody else stayed the same the
democratic party just moved wildly to
the left and when the democratic party
of today is too far left for the
democratic party of 2010 that shows you
how far left they've moved because the
democratic party of 2010 was not a
moderate party already we will be back
here later today with an additional hour
of content in the meantime go check out
the michael knowles show today he
discusses joe biden saying that george
floyd mattered more than martin luther
king jr you can hear more details about
that story over on michael's show that's
available right now i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover and our production manager
is pavo widowski associate producer
bradford carrington editing is by adam's
high event audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
christina production assistant jessica
krand the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
joe biden says george floyd mattered
more than martin luther king israel
finds that even a fourth covid shot does
not stop amicron and dr fauci's
financial disclosures show that the
vaunted doctor is
loaded check it out on the michael
knowles show